oh
[Musique]
bon
je suis à l'évier gingras et j'ai étudié
au collège on tique
j'ai eu un accident il ya sept ans c'est
pourquoi je suis en fauteuil roulant
en 2009 le 6 septembre 2009 plus
précisément
j'étais à mon chalet on était sur le
bord du lac qui ont ce billet puis j'ai
plongé trois profondeur qui mate est
touché le fond de l'eau puis dans le
fond ça le cas c'est mon coup les
vertèbres c3 c4
[Musique]
je peux pas bouger rien qui est en
dessous de mes épaules
mais au début c'est sûr que j'étais
fâché parce que du jour au lendemain tu
peux plus bouger dit pu faire tout
qu'est ce que tu faisais avant mais
après j'ai appris à vivre avec un
handicap pis à partir de ce moment là je
lis bien pris
je venais de commencer l'école ça
faisait deux semaines à peu près puis le
chiche avec j'avais manqué une année au
moins puis ça peut aller encore plus
fait que c'est sur le coup c'est ce qui
m'a le plus atteint plus que le fait
savoir que j'allais pas bougé
[Musique]
j'ai regardé les choses que je pouvais
encore faire et non les choses que je
pourrais plus faire
kla j'ai vu qu' il y avait plusieurs
possibilités puisque la vitre et
s'étaient pas juste de bouger puis de
faire comme tout le monde fait que c'est
vraiment comme ça que j'ai appris à bien
vivre avec
dans le fond d'avoir ma taille shillings
en son temps le plus important leur
facture pour moi le corpus mousse
important mais tant que tu as ta tête tu
peux pas quelque chose
[Musique]
du droit passe à travers l'image part ça
peut venir d'une autre session puis en
ce moment je suis en suis en semaine
mais j'aimerais changer pour aller en
informatique
j'ai tout le temps d'une hauteur de la
moyenne ça va vraiment bien je me suis
fait des amis jeunes accompagnatrices
qui me suit à l'école ça va vraiment
bien
[Musique]
les enfants seront pas gêné c'est qu'il
va venir me demander qu'est ce que tu as
souvent les parents sont comme nan on
parle pas le demande mais moi ça me fait
plaisir et je leur ai expliqué en même
temps avec je fais de la prévention
[Musique]
pendant cinq à dix ans j'aimerais avoir
ma compagnie de jeux vidéo ça j'aimerais
vraiment seuls assistés comme le but
scène pour un jour à voir sur mon
appartement ma maison la série manche le
plus juste de prendre une marche
c'est drôle à dire parce que quand on
marche on y pense pratique on trouve ce
parce qu'en plus ils s'éclatent
mais c'est quelque chose que j'aimerais
une sinon ça pourrait être séjour
baseball je suis gay serait le fun me
semble
[Musique]